you know how fired up i am right now
we've got good barbecue here this in my
mind there really is no better way to
start off the new year or the end of the
year or the middle of the year other
than enjoying some fantastic barbecue
and that's why soul belly would be a
great place to ring in 2022 we are
joined by one of the partners richard
camarota and you guys have a lot of
things going on for new year's eve we do
it's gonna be a fun night we have uh
awesome food and great uh live music
it's gonna be a fun time we're gonna
have hot sauce which is our house band
and they play with chef bruce common up
there so you can even do some karaoke
we've done that as well it's been a
great time so uh when you say you you
don't mean me you if you'd heard me do
karaoke you would not invite me it's
about the spirit it's about the spirit
you don't have to sound good i don't go
singing up there either i'm pretty awful
but uh yeah it's gonna be a great night
and then a great day uh new year's day
with some great barbecue if you're
feeling a little uh worse for the wear
man i'll tell you i've heard great
things about your barbecue and you guys
are relatively new and just opened up
this year we did we opened in may of
this year yeah that's a challenge right
there had that been in the works for a
long time a little bit yeah you know
chef and i met uh about uh 18 months ago
two years ago and we started talking
about this project and got it off the
ground it's been really exciting since
but did you say first let's go through a
pandemic sure and really test the metal
exactly and open up as it's starting to
ease up exactly but i hear great things
and you've got some cool stuff planned
for new year's eve we do so uh you know
we got a great selection of craft beer
we use uh
we support all the local breweries in
town uh one night next door to us called
huddle uh
we also support a lot of the local guys
as well we make some amazing cocktails
this is one of our jiggle juice which is
a
maker's mark infused basically uh lemon
uh lemonade uh and then we have some
amazing barbecue so it's all kind of
classically done texas style with two
offset smokers we've got some amazing
ribs pulled pork brisket some smoked
chicken we also do turkey and then we
make our own sausages in-house this is a
texas roasted garlic beef sausage and we
also do a pork and cheddar hot like oh i
love it so if we go there and obviously
well i could i could say load me up on
everything but if you can only have one
or two you want the two meat special
which ones would you recommend to people
you know i think everybody loves and
always goes for the brisket you know
that's always the as a good texas man
yourself yeah i would say any good
barbecue joint is judged by its brisket
so that's a good place to start i mean
the ribs are a nice option as well i
mean at the same time i love chicken as
well i mean it's it's a great piece of
meat yeah and pulled pork pork's always
it's not a bad it is it is it is and
then we have awesome sides you know we
always joke uh you know some barbecue
restaurants saying i forget about the
sides but you know we all come from a
chef background and it's really
important to us to make great great size
so we've got uh awesome green beans we
talked with a little bit of a pimento
relish we've got some amazing mac and
cheese we make the pasta in house make
everything in-house coleslaw and then
chef's favorite it's a little corn
casserole it's kind of a play on
something his uh his wife does and so
yeah we got all sorts of different well
i believe you the sides are good i ain't
touching them i'm just going in there
i'm going to eat the meat
fair enough all right so where can
people find soul belly we're located
right out on main street right between
uh on imperial and uh 1327 south main
street all right congratulations on your
success thus far uh wish you the best
going into the new year as well yeah
thanks for having us go to seoul belly
enjoy the barbecue i'm about to we'll be
right back